this slow-motion video of a bat drinking
from a pool of water was made by German
scientists Stefan greif and Beyond zimas
the / set out to investigate the sensory
cues that help animals recognize
features in their environment in this
case the ponds and rivers that bats use
for orientation in foraging
we know a lot about how bats use
echolocation to target insect sized
objects but this is the first study to
show how they recognize large flat
objects like ponds Stefan and Bjorn
caught wild bats in Bulgaria and tested
them in a large dark flight room they
presented the bats with either smooth or
textured plates positioned on the flight
rooms sandy floor when presented with a
smooth plate of metal the bats treated
it like water and tried to drink
even when the metal plate was put on a
table a very unnatural position for a
pond the researchers watched as the bats
attempted to quench their thirst a
smooth metal plate reflects sound in the
same way as a body of water so this
behavior supported the researchers
hypothesis that bats rely on the mirror
like echo reflection properties of
smooth surfaces to recognize water in
their environment when a bat flies above
a smooth surface most of the sound waves
in its call are reflected away but a
small proportion hit the surface
immediately below and then bounce back a
telltale sign of water if you're a bat
Stephan and Bjorn also tested young bats
that had never encountered a pond or
river before these naive bats also tried
to drink from the metal plate this was
the first time in their lives these
youngsters had encountered a large
smooth surface so this suggests that
water recognition in bats is hardwired
into the brain and the researchers claim
this is the first evidence for innate
recognition of a habitat cue such as a
pond in a mammal
you